no no
no this is the return of one of our
favorite characters
skippy oh no wanna let you guys know
this video will not end how you are
expecting
it will blow your mind so watch it
through
okay so it's getting near the time when
i'm going to leave and go pick up tracy
i love when they fix their hair and they
do nothing with their head
and nothing changed our best you made it
worse
you know what listen i appreciate that
you combed your hair and you look like a
mess
i mean i'm not gonna talk because i look
like a mess but i don't even pretend to
comb my hair
no i just come out looking but sometimes
you pretend like you cut it and then you
really use
it like you cut it with a butter knife
yeah but at least you know you're not
gonna
know what i also did save 20 on a barber
i know that we're just friends she's
paying
for dinner possibly
which yeah that's a pretty good sign
that we're just friends and who knows
whether or not we'll be
eating afterwards or what we'll be doing
afterwards or if there will be an
afterwards or if it's just going to be
walking
her straight back here she says i'm
paying for my half to dinner or just
friends
and you're still holding out hope that
you might take her back home
whoa like i said you know what i mean
first floor
friend zone the basement simp zone okay
you're deep in the sim zone
okay we'll call that a cave not a not a
basement
in the cave a whole gulag
yeah on the chance that it's more of a
date and there's a chance that i might
get
close enough to give her an actual kiss
guys guys
what the woman tell you is what it is
don't assume that it's something else
that's it
what they tell you is what it is oh you
want to go back to my place
it's that until further notice
oh yeah we going back to your place
oh yeah girl yeah
oh we're just gonna study
no i was hot i was
hot i'm gonna put my shirt back on
that's tracy you remember tracy
you smell nice you look great how about
i get up and give you a hug
if i give you a hug and i go like i just
bit into some pillsbury doughboy
we got a problem how about i get up and
give you a hug
he even says it like hannibal lecter
before he's about to dice
hey clarice how about i get up and give
you a hug
so creepy bro so you've been
going all day and then you're heading
out camping tonight right
yeah which is my getaway so i can look
at some stars how long are you going
camping for
uh just um over one night
just one night are you going camping
with someone i know
you're nice it's under your business
nice what's the worst she's not cheating
on you bro
busted what's busted he's busted
he been busted and guess who did that
m-o-m-a
watch thank you guys that way yo mama yo
mama
god damn whoa it's hard to get through
let us know which point in this video
you clicked out by the way i hope you
know that i'm teasing you with it
i don't care that you have another date
care bears you care you care
you care you care a lot you care yes you
got hurt like i'm super thrilled
just that we're on a date
you're absolutely gorgeous and you were
my date to this tonight
you are monday it's not a date you're
pissing me
gorgeous as my date it's not a date
business i just want to say that i was
the luckiest guy to be on a date with
you
if you're not my date i just want to say
that i
may have had the loveliest date in the
whole state
my dad i just want to say
that we are now in a facebook
relationship and i'm so grateful you
were my date
[ __ ] take a clue blue's clues i don't
care what you need to do
put it on a billboard what is you
talking about it's not a date
god damn yo this guy is the embodiment
of speaking into existence
this [ __ ] says if he just screams it
enough out of wall it'll happen
you're awesome as can be the fact that
you're not wearing a bra
has been so easy tonight free the nipple
free the nipple dude
yeah lost cause this man single-handedly
banished
self-awareness to the shadow realm this
man this man is on a roll my [ __ ] well
and
i think that i've done a very good job
of not staring or
looking that way
[Music]
no it's you it's not the others shut the
[ __ ] up
if you see titties you shut up and if
you speak up
you're never going to be able to see
them again that's when they hide them
just let them be don't comment don't
stare can we just
enjoy whenever the [ __ ] they're there
what are you doing
and it doesn't make you a good person if
you go up to somebody like hey man
by the way i just want to let you know i
had hundreds of opportunities to rob you
and i didn't rob you now in my head i'm
like
why would you say that yeah and now i'm
in my head i'm like
oh you've been thinking about robbing me
you had hundreds of opportunities
meaning every time you walked by you're
like
i could rub this [ __ ] i can rub this
thing
how about i tell you this it gets way
worse
you're not like other girls i am smitten
but i don't think i'm as smitten as you
think i'm smitten
like i played tonight really cool didn't
i
like have i been okay have i been
uptight about anything
no yeah you're totally cool actually
is it jack
i told y'all you don't want to miss this
this gets crazy
hey i haven't bothered you out all night
i don't bother you at all was it jack
was it bill was it angel
who amos no leo
no i haven't bothered you all right i've
been a good date right you're my date
right we're just friends but you're
still the best date that i've ever had
right first i'm just asking is it jesus
no is it trump no is it preach are you
on a date with priests later
what are you going to do with tell me
you are the best date that i've ever had
it's not a date
you are the greatest that a man could
ever ask for you didn't wear a bra and i
didn't stare at your titties aren't i a
good person
i haven't bothered you all night right
no is it jack
nice people people that are that are
watching english
i've been saying a word like sisters you
got to be [ __ ] kidding me tell them
all right all right all right now you
know okay there's a hot
there's a pause so that makes me think
that that could be it
he's a stud by the way if it's like a
maniac you're being a maniac right now
would you tell me no if it would you
tell me no if it wasn't him
just drop it like it's hot drop it like
it's hot sun okay like it's hot
okay drop it like it's hot you think you
go get this kiss
not you come at me with the wrong energy
bro you and i got no synergy stop
looking at me because the way i be
is not for thee you are sam
walking out here talking like you were
pimp
[ __ ] your dick has gone limp
i don't know why you going higher the
high pitches
nah nah nah cause i come straight
the way gay [ __ ] come dick what what
puffs
i told this man yo you skippy because
i'ma skip you on to the next one
it's tender swipe left like i got more
heft
in the gun run you haven't said [ __ ] nah
nah
you said i say [ __ ] cause you can't see
the words the way they went
on the verse you can't see the herd of
thoughts that i'm putting down
on the table bro you know i'm able
bodies i ain't gimpy like skippy
ooh bro i'm coming here with the hiffy
hiffy's izzy
lay like zaza
what's wrong with you like
[Laughter]
exactly
okay okay that's how you do it baby
okay so how do we get so turned off by
any of that weird [ __ ] you guys
can't do that so how do we end tonight
milliseconds
after she said i'm turned off by all the
witch
that you pulled off tonight he goes
the audacity he goes how do we end it
tonight
bruh well thus ends the official date
and she said that we could call it a
date now some of you are wondering why
would she say that at the end of the day
after all that
because this dude is being super creepy
and pushy nonstop
at some point she's probably worried
about her safety in a genuine manner
this man does not look like he's well in
the head and that's a problem a lot of
dudes have they approach these
relationships under the guise of
friendship
yeah we're friends we're friends but in
the back of their head they've already
imagined
every scenario in which they're not
going to be friends they try to push
themselves
into into something else yeah
upgrade their status that is not the way
to do that it's creepy
guys is is bad that is not the way to do
that and
and ladies this is what i'm saying if a
dude has romantic feelings for you
understand trying to be friends with
that person is not to your benefit
and it's a risk normally so all that's
left to do is
go home
doesn't this look like a cell phone
video for facebook live before he goes
and murders somebody in life doesn't
know what that looks like
like i'm just waiting to see something
gory
oh
tracy it's me skippy no
no no no
no don't break it no
oh
[Music]
guys man we just went on a date together
oh do i get to find out
holy cow it is david what's going on
dude ladies and gentlemen we talked
about him tonight earlier on the day
this is david
hey how's it going skippy man what is
going on
and you guys met via uh instagram
instagram now
wow and you it makes so much sense you
guys have so much stuff in common with
all the
jogging that you do yeah oh man
tracy tracy you guys are a cute couple
you totally have my blessing the
blessing i'm preached
and i don't even bless them you know why
because i don't give a [ __ ] because i
shouldn't give a [ __ ]
and neither should you what is this
preach as much right to bless them as
you do in that scenario
because you are nothing to her the same
way he's nothing to her i have more
chances than you
i actually have more chat because she
doesn't know me to be a creep
so i creep yeah
this is not on the down low this is up
high in your face no no
yeah that's not that yeah yeah
no no no this is not nothing it's not
loki's nike he's
hiking i'm not sure she'll tell you this
so i'll tell it to you
i went in for a kiss tonight uh in the
uh in the elevator right with the camera
off
trying to be a gentleman and yeah
as the door was closing camera was off
and
uh got rejected we really did kiss
she and i kissed the one time it was
amazing
if you haven't kissed her yet you'll
you'll definitely enjoy it
like it's a car you test out like ugh
you got problems skippy for real
i wish you the best
but get some counseling all right there
we go get some
counseling because that's not normal
give me a hug man
i will a while we went to uvu together
you know what good for them
good for freaking them
[Music]
[Applause]
i felt like the motorcycle was perfectly
exemplifying what's probably going on
the inside yeah the eggs off
he got cucked at the end so hard he
hugged the guy
who was with the girl he wanted to be he
didn't cook he didn't get cupped
he cooked himself the guy went yo give
me a hug man cause
you you feel bad you feel heartbroken
you you the guy was like yo give me a
hug cause you need it more than i do
cause i'm about to that's none of your
business
but you need a hug and i understand the
guy because you're not
why would you that's not normal god damn
this is the only thing i'll say
i think his problem is that he doesn't
see
another individual he sees a potential
from romantic experience he's not seeing
the person he's not listening to them
he's not really hearing them he's just
like what can i get out of this
i want to get kissed i wanna so when
this person's communicating hey you're
making me uncomfortable he doesn't
listen
he's not hearing this so to me it's like
you're not talking to a person it might
as well be a doll
that has rights you feel what i'm saying
yeah so
i think that's his biggest problem and i
think a lot of people engage in dating
that way they don't
see another person across from them
they're just like what can i get out of
this you're seeing how it manifests
terribly for himself
so that's really uncomfortable to watch
at some points
um super cringy but yeah there are men
like this out there
they are out there and that is a problem
that's all i got never in your life do
some [ __ ] like that again bro
whatever the [ __ ] that was what do you
mean
you don't know what this is this is a
content
[Music]
foreign